[Music]
one comic is better than the other
people think it's them we're smoking and
joking and having a blast two Comics two
cigars two Comics two cigars
[Music]
yeah
all right welcome everybody to another
episode of two Comics two cigars I like
that two Comics two cigars
one wife is younger and has potential
one wife is also
from Boston oh that's a good one you
went nine different directions you
pulled back I've just realized I put
these sneakers on because it was raining
yeah and I bought them in 2013. but
these are still Level ones I could
really wear these what's a level one
level I'm not a sneaker guy I have a new
balance I wear New Balance because I
have plantar fasciitis and I'm old and
it's the most comfortable shoe on the
planet Earth and they just decided to
get a little fancy you know what I mean
yeah what is a level one yeah you got
sneakers on that I I can see at night
right yeah because I'm walking yeah if
you're walking at night I can take the
dog up
those are reflective sneakers yes these
uh these are Y3 Adidas collaboration
with
johoto he's some Japanese designer is
that [ __ ] real yeah it's real yeah yo
what yeah
I never I can't pronounce you know yo he
is
and I got these on Lincoln Road in Miami
when I was Miami honest in 2013.
remember that yeah remember those phone
calls yes and um the highs the highs and
the lowest of lows it was the highest
behind the lowest lows I was going
through heartbreak but I was also living
like Don Johnson in Miami Vice
[ __ ] it was a good time I had
Florida window I have floor-to-ceiling
Windows
I had oh yeah yeah we had lost a lot of
weight I was real slim down because I
was depressed I wasn't eating yeah
because I I was I I broke up are you the
convertible I had a BMW converting right
it wasn't a converting wow they don't
know that no one's ever gonna know what
do you think they're fact checking here
they didn't I should have just went with
it yeah I was fact checking I got to fix
it yeah it was a convertible I had a
Lambo you're right I should just keep
going I got a Lambo yeah you should have
just I mean I don't know what you're
doing here nobody cares I had a Cuban I
had a Cuban girlfriend oh speaking of
Cubans listen to me we've done a lot now
this is this everybody knows this
podcast it's two Comics two cigars and
the other rules are no women allowed no
they can okay
not in the shed
not on this show not in the show but no
you you could be two women Comics you
could be you can be two women's just not
on this show no you can be on the show
no listen when you got a [ __ ] you can't
be understood that's true if you have a
[ __ ] and you're a comic you have to be a
comic but you smoke cigars only if
you've transitioned or taken
testosterone no that's this is man [ __ ]
we're doing if you're transitioning and
you smoke cigars and you're a comic you
can be on the show it's just two Comics
two sisters and you have to smoke the
same cigar and that's it then we talk
about it the the beginning and we talk
about the middle and at the end and then
we rate at the end zero one five or a
box okay okay none one five or a box can
I rate it a box or does it have to be a
box it has to be a well it's got to be a
box do I say box you guys say box I say
box you box yeah has to be a box it has
to be a box okay and this is a special
one
because I got these cigars sent to me
from one of my favorite people in the
world Russell Peters Russell Peters one
of the most generous comics
I've ever encountered well he can afford
to be well yeah a lot I know a lot of
guys that are conformed to me and are
nickel Chasers yeah I know a guy who
used to make me pay for Quiznos yeah who
had a black card in his sock then cook
oh no Jesus Christ
I just took a wild guess no I really
like me you can't
anyways yeah let's just say he he can't
be on two Comics two cigars oh [ __ ]
Ari's calling Jesus and he's ruining the
shot is it in [ __ ] Rosh Hashanah or
something yes I already beat it you
shouldn't be using it's still working
why is Ari allowed to use electricity
after Sundown oh he quit up I did that's
right so the cigars that he sent me
because he gets shipments from Cuba or
kosher no Cuban cigars but this is a sky
you've never smoked you ever smoke a
punch I've never smoked a Cuban punch
okay you smoked a regular punch I smoked
a regular punch okay well a lot of
people sleep on punch
a lot of people don't go for punch punch
had a big thing back when I was me and
Gary gallman I started smoking cigars on
punch me and Gary would split a box of
50. and we'd smoke weed comic books
after we worked at an Italian restaurant
in Boston and we'd smoke in the Park
after and just smoke these little Maduro
Maduro punches and I love punch and I
forgot about them they kind of fell to
the Wayside with all this you know all
the boutique things out there now and
all the you know but this cigar right
here is gonna I think gonna you're gonna
enjoy this okay why because it's not too
crazy and it's free which is always good
and it's Cuban it's cute but it's a good
Cubit yeah so it means it's definitely
not a socialist cigar oh look at that
well you got a whole box dude look I
gotta [ __ ] smell that smell that
oh God come on smells like Fidel Castro
look at that look at that size
look at this is a cigar this is a man's
cigar buddy I could smell the Bay of
Pigs on this I mean dude you can't [ __ ]
with this
right you have a whole box of these I
got a whole box and we're gonna enjoy
wow and listen this would come this is
it mine this is is this Mario Lopez's
Edition why what is it because mine says
Mario Lopez on it from Saved by the Bell
it's from no it's actually his oh manual
I don't have my glasses I don't have my
glasses either Manuel Lopez all right
here we go yeah cutting the top off
you want me to cut yours for you you
want to cut it I'm the guest really I
think you should cut it I know well all
right so like I always say make a little
fish out of there right little fisheye
in the thing yeah see that and then snip
it off and there you go beautiful take
that top cap off and then we're gonna
toast it
we're gonna toast this little baby do it
right toasting toasting Oh I thought we
were gonna do a toast like cheers
I wish my dick was that big and thin me
too yeah yeah
oh my [ __ ] my lighter just ran out
yeah I'm unprofessional but you know
what my Rocky Patel always comes into
play
not a great cigar Rocky Patel here you
go are you uh yeah Rocky Patel it seems
like people a lot of people don't like
Rocky patels you're out of your mind we
toast that hold that up you stay where'd
you get that from someone likes you
cigar here's the rule yeah don't move
don't try to you don't do anything you
just stay still you let stay still you
let me do everything stay still don't
follow it you're following it you're
such an alpha male you can't just let
somebody do something there you go there
you go look at that you're lit dude
you're a [ __ ] ah [ __ ] you're lit
where'd you get that thing Don Draper
Jesus looks like a madman problem Mad
Men yeah this is a beautiful beautiful
Rocky Patel ladder one of my favorite
ladders always for some reason I get
this my friend Rob Dukes made this this
is a piston from a car but it's an
ashtray
um he had one of his microphones in
there it's over there somewhere and
we'll move this back and then we'll use
this
um
I mean
out of the gate this cigar oh my God
out of the gate this cigar
is [ __ ] phenomenal it's a light
delicious smoke right out of the gate I
mean dude
you know why I love this cigar
the size
the size of the cigar makes you feel
like you own a business you're up in
some exclu wherever the [ __ ] you are
we're in a shed I feel about I'm an
exclusive Lounge on the 90th floor of a
building in Manhattan and me and just
closed the big deal yeah these cigars
are so good the cigars almost didn't let
us smoke them in here yeah
squirrel's like you guys gotta go to
Fifth Avenue
and be businessman and put on shoes with
tassels and have a scotch could you
imagine why haven't they upgraded the
suit
why haven't they made it something else
why have guys still dressing like
[ __ ] idiots every day
uncomfortable pants about a [ __ ]
button-down a tie a jacket even in the
summer yeah well I think we've come a
long way I was a part of that sneaker
Civil Rights Movement what was that
where the right to wear sneakers at work
and to write the what the right to wear
sneakers is Formal Wear I was a part of
that generation I was like part of the
Rosa Parks generation of wearing
sneakers as formal wear and I think
we've come a long way we got a long way
to go right but we've come a long way in
our movement well you're a sneakerhead
right yeah you and Versi yeah and now
sneakers you can get in clubs with
sneakers you can get it in fact in like
New York City and like cool cities like
New York Miami L.A if you're wearing
shoes and you go into like a fancy
trendy restaurant it looks weird you're
like who's this kid who's this kid from
the suburbs of Chicago here's a problem
with sneakers that are cool they don't
they're not comfortable there's never
cool comfortable it's either cool or
comfortable let me tell you something I
just got 1080
1080 x 12 New Balance slip-ons no lace
podiatrist approved dude I don't give a
[ __ ] they are Ramos because I feel like
I'm walking on air yeah there's the
thing
I don't want to stereotype all kids from
Boston
I know what a stereotype kids from
Boston but you guys are a little
it's a little you're a little behind
like the fashion is always like a little
behind dude guys I think we're ahead
you're not ahead
you're not I must stick up for Boston
right now yeah first of all we're the
ones who [ __ ] Larry Bird Converse
okay we're the ones wearing Shell Toes
before anybody
okay we will oh they're called shell
tops those two we're wearing shell top
Shell Toes shell heels okay we'll run on
the ocean [ __ ] we're wearing
shells yeah no Boston you know
God bless Boston kids but it's like you
know it's usually like a Carhartt jacket
with like Timbo boots yeah we made that
that's how you guys go to the wedding
but we made that cool I guess you made
that cool but then the girls God bless
them you'll see a girl like a Boston hat
bell bottoms like bell bottom jeans with
like uh like stiletto high heels it's
just a confusing it's it's pieces it's
different
pieces of the outfit that would would
signify you're doing something different
that night all in the same outfit like
you like to go to a Bon Jovi concert the
Celtics game yeah and to a formal dinner
yeah
and what outfit because you know what
yeah we do that you never know where the
night's gonna take you you never know
whether how you feeling this right now
it's smooth it's light now is it light
because the rapper is light because I
heard that is a cigar light when the
rapper's light and the darker the cigar
I I'm I'm not gonna
no some I mean yes it's called the
Connecticut wrap when it's light they
have different out uh the the the filler
is always could be different it depends
though it depends there's you know some
fillers some cigars are
um
not as not not that Maduro you know what
I mean
um some Maduro is a light it depends on
the filler it depends on what they're
mixing it how long it was aged how long
it you know they let it ferment and what
other tobaccos they mix it with this
cigar is mixed with a bunch of different
you know uh
parts of the plant or from one from over
here one from over there that you know
um
so I love the smell of the cigar I think
that um but in general if you see a
cigar this color a light tan or even a a
lighter tan than it will be lighter
it'll be milder then a dark like a
Wesley Snipes [ __ ] so a lot of the
tastes of this cigar is actually the
wrapper no some of it is it's what's
inside some of it is yeah yeah because
if it's like a little harsher or better
or it's a little darker it's a little
yeah yeah some of it is but it's really
what's inside it's it's you know what
they what they choose to fill it with
you know the what leaves we went to the
farm
uh you know I went to a farm and uh it's
pretty fascinating
how they you know the different parts of
the plant
and and and how they process the plant
like you go in if these plants out don't
look right there's [ __ ] tobacco you know
sweets [ __ ] like that that's garbage
what's that called Swisher Sweets what's
oh the Philly buns yeah
a lot of pot smokers will fill them with
weed and [ __ ] like that charade will be
up front with the Swisher Sweets yeah
they'll just be taking the tobacco out
and putting the weed in and then licking
it back up yeah yeah you know but you
know then you have the you know the
high-end [ __ ] that tobacco leaf that you
know fermented right and hung it right
and they and it's got oils and it looks
perfect and you know and then they age
it for two years two to three years
that's why some of these cigars take
years to make
because there the this tobacco sitting
in a room somewhere just fermenting it
smells like sheep [ __ ] oh because you've
been in one right I've been in a couple
yeah you got so into cigars once you
started smoking them but I didn't know
you were smoking them in Boston with
Gary Goldman before I spoke to guys a
long time ago I got way into them when I
got out of rehab and went and did comedy
then I worked at the restaurant and then
me and Gary started smoking then my
friend Ricky buccini from Quincy he was
a hairdresser I love this kid yeah Ricky
buccini's
he did he make it it doesn't sound like
a Puccini's ever going to make it out of
Quincy or he dude not he didn't make it
out of Quincy you're right yeah but he
made it you know he's money [ __ ]
hairdresser like he he he's his
hairdresser dude
I mean slick back hair in a braid
[ __ ] dressed to the nines all the
time is he a good guy or no no straight
as [ __ ] I mean do a Quincy this guy he
hung out would kill us yeah I mean dude
you you don't [ __ ] with these guys yeah
you know and you don't come out Quincy
you don't [ __ ] with you can't come out
and quit that's Dorchester Quincy that's
the sound you gotta go down Paul
downtown Boston to come out yeah you
can't even come out in Quincy probably
no no Quincy won't let you the town will
stop you maybe now but not back then
yeah but dude I remember he his he had
such big balls and we'd be walking you
know a night out down on Newbury Street
going to some club or something some
restaurant try to score some chicks and
we'd have to stop because he'd have to
untangle his balls he'd literally have
to reach in and he'd be hunched over I
mean look you know [ __ ] brand new
jeans shirt gold chain hair back we're
all ready to go and he's sitting there
right on Newbury Street reaching that
untwisting his balls because they were
so big
and he used to [ __ ] his pants all the
time too [ __ ] hilarious and he became
a hairdresser and he's straight straight
straight yeah funny [ __ ] guy dude not
too many people made me laugh straight
people the squares
didn't make me this Square would crack
me the [ __ ] up him and Mark Caesar one
of my best friends the guy who helped me
get sober if it wasn't for Mark Caesar
I got out of rehab 14 months in rehab
the guy in read I go I I well what the
[ __ ] oh is that I mean there's an
ashtray right I apologize I mean that's
just a rookie Ding-A-Ling a ling-a-ling
yes I mean you'd be fine I mean what the
[ __ ] yeah well you know I do smoke
cigars I am a cigar lover and I love
cigars it is funny when you smoke
someone who like doesn't smoke cigars
and you can see the way they hold it
like yeah they're always going like this
is a big one here
yeah yeah how about this
yeah but they just touch it now I spoke
to someone one time who said you're not
supposed to put the whole thing in your
mouth you're supposed to do like that
and pull it for some reason yeah you
know the thing about cigars is
everyone has these little things that
they tell you all right like it's like a
because it's like a connoisseur thing
yeah like wine yeah somebody will throw
you a tip and I remember I was smoking
at some Cigar Lounge watching the guy
was like you know you see he was like
it's wet he was like you don't want that
you want to go like put your mouth to it
yeah employees that could taste better
and I try to you know
that's what he told me
I'm like is that true I went through all
this over the last 10 years of smoking
cigars and before but very in the last
10 I've every place I go every town I go
to I go to the cigar bar and I talk to
people I'm really into the the whole
culture of cigar making I love it
um because it's like you know I guess it
would be my wine or my bourbon right but
I remember when I was sitting there all
this stuff the lighters the the you know
how to cut it how to let and then I saw
this old guy come into my cigar lounge
he [ __ ] pinched the tip off the just
with his fingernail lit it with a Bic
and then [ __ ] smoked it and enjoyed
the [ __ ] I was like
that's it whatever you however you enjoy
a cigar you enjoy it so that's the way
that guy he enjoyed smoking it like this
he was he didn't need a fancy ladder he
didn't need a you know a cutter he
didn't need all the to toast he didn't
need it's like you smoke it enjoy it
he's trying he's sitting there
it was in hell in this cigar so you do
what you want I mean to be honest with
you
looks like you're playing a flute
you do taste it a little better so that
so he maybe he was right yeah but you
look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] so it's up
to you I'll never ever go with you
anywhere if you're doing this yeah
I'll [ __ ] I'll never take you
anywhere yeah it does taste a little
different though it's a little smoother
it's a little yeah lighter almost even
too
I mean let's do it for this for this
show let's do it that way ah just do
pickle sniffers this is what you call
Churchill length
right these are Churchill size I believe
so yeah exact kid loves cigars so much
that they name the size after him yeah
really yeah I mean Winston Churchill
he's a no double Corona he's a double
Corona double Corona yeah so spiritual
is uh I think a little maybe a little
bigger thicker than this
maybe yeah because that's how he liked
to smoke them so they just named it
after him
now what is it about the Cuban tobacco
like why what's the difference between
the cube and tobacco and I the Dominican
tobacco Nicaraguan what's the difference
buddy it's
Nicaragua and tobacco is probably better
than Cuban yeah that's what that's why I
like to David off Nicaraguan is one of
my favorite sticks I know it's one of
versy's favorite sticks he turned me on
to the Davidoff Nicaraguan when I first
started smoking sticks I was smoking
davidoffs this kid I knew turned me on
to davidoffs and davidoffs are good
they're good stuff is good but you gotta
you better have some cash they're
expensive you're not smoking every day
no unless you got a lot my doctor my
daughter our pan he smokes down and
they're Nicaraguan right like a rock
yeah Nicaragua but the Cuban does taste
amazing tastes great yeah it's great
it's it's got It's got the history it's
the Cuban cigar it's hard to get you
can't just get them so there's a there's
a whole factor into getting a cube and I
I feel when somebody gives me a Cuban
cigar I'm like thank you very much it's
a special thing but Nicaraguan is just
as good you think it's Nicaraguan is
absolutely a hundred percent good yeah
100 just as good yeah it's it's volcanic
Earth
you know what I mean they've been
growing them there forever what do you
mean volcanic Earth it's the Earth this
[ __ ] volcanic earthquake they have a
like a whole they have like
a shitload of if you look at a map
what is it uh
what was that word
no typo
typical and I know it's usually I'm the
rapper no tabagas
foreign typography oh topography so
photography is one of those words you
can't say without a English accent
topography that's why I couldn't say it
with a Boston accent it doesn't come out
no [ __ ] typography typography
typography
dude the typography if you look at the
typography it is a typography yeah
British it's a typography
um there's just volcanoes dudes
surrounding though I mean it's just all
it's like all these volcanoes and that
that's why like in Connecticut grows
great tobacco why
we talked about this before the the
Connecticut River was a finger Lake of
the Great Lakes right it cracked open
started draining into the Long Island
Sound became the Connecticut River right
it's thinned out so now it's not a lake
all that land that Connecticut's built
on Sand right and clay from the riverbed
it's a riverbed that's why they grow
great Tobacco on the Connecticut River
oh so it's all that stuff so tobacco can
grow just anywhere no don't forget this
too the other thing that sucks about up
here is that the seasons suck down in
nicaraguans it's you know it's beautiful
it's it's a it's a humid but we I mean
we
one of the big crops that started this
country was tobacco how come they don't
make amazing cigars in like Virginia
they make cigarettes like Virginia's
tobacco we have so many tobacco
plantations I think yeah absolutely but
I think a lot of the we had tobacco
Plantation a lot I said we have I said
that we had yeah I don't say plantations
but that's what they were but um past
tense a lot of the uh blenders a lot of
the uh Master blood they went to
Nicaragua they you know after Cuba they
went there so you're talking about these
guys who know how to who know how to
blend tobacco who know how to age it
ferment it you know it's not just
growing tobacco growing tobacco it has
is a part of it but it's there's so much
more that goes into it so you gotta you
gotta see this leaf and that leaf and
this will be my rapper that'll be my
filler that'll be you know all this
stuff that goes into it and then you
have to try it oh that's it so these
these there's so much that goes into it
can I fart on this you can fight you
[ __ ] if you can [ __ ] your pants right
now I'll clean you out in the rain I'll
[ __ ] put your bum out the door let
the rain wash it out you sit back down I
don't even care I don't think you can
fart when you're smoking a cigar you can
shoot your pants I think I've done that
I had one but then I held it and it went
back up nah don't do that it'll be back
it'll be back you know it's like a guy
who's you owe money to when you hold the
fart in it'll be back oh it comes back
yeah it comes back yeah it comes back
knocking what was that Sammy pants
to be honest with you I've never fully
[ __ ] my pants I have amazing sphincter
control I peed the bed the last time I
did that was in was in summer camp when
I was a kid but I've never fully [ __ ] my
pants isn't that amazing dude I [ __ ] my
pants two weeks ago
you did
[Music]
yeah 100 yeah yeah I had to run to the
shower and [ __ ] just hose myself off
I had to throw my underwear how
embarrassed I was my wife went why your
underwear in the trash I was that guy
[ __ ] they're clean I washed it I [ __ ] my
pants full-on [ __ ] or just a shark
because I've done tons of [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh uh
copper oatmeal into my pants
it was
not a good one I [ __ ] and it went up the
elastic like it I mean I just
thank God the underwear kept it in but
it went there was like two centimeters
until it was coming out the pop side
yeah oh yeah that thing was coming out
like where were you how come you
couldn't get to a bathroom dude I was
right there I was in my bed I went to
take a nap and I was I had a nice tooth
I thought it was a two
and all the protein shakes all the
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] I'm drinking yeah
it just comes out sometimes liquid dude
I went uh and and I immediately I've
tooted there's been many times I've
tweeted oh my god did I just [ __ ] and I
didn't I'm like thank God but I knew
immediately
I just [ __ ] my pants it felt like
somebody threw up in my underwear
[Laughter]
I just and it's the hard part when you
[ __ ] your pants
is getting your pants off without
[ __ ] stepping in [ __ ] yeah you know
like you gotta you don't want to touch
[ __ ] you don't want your foot you want
you want because you [ __ ] through to the
bed did you sit on the bed no no no no
no no no no no no if you're quick enough
yeah look if I [ __ ] and lied there it
was gonna seep through right but if
you're quick enough with a poop yeah you
gotta yeah yeah I mean and the problem
is if it if it was a regular like a
healthy [ __ ] you could if you're a
healthy person like these protein the
like the protein I think I think I had
some soup or something that [ __ ] me up
because I'm drinking these protein
shakes right I'm looking over like
there's one here yeah yeah the protein
shake just add that inside I could
action this thing too right sure yeah
it's the Rob Dukes ashtray yeah
um protein [ __ ] is solid as a rock it's
Clay you can build a house if I was in
the jam yeah you could build the house
and you turn it into a brick yeah oh you
could yeah you could yeah I could make a
whole [ __ ] little kitchen a bathroom
a [ __ ] bedroom of my [ __ ] so you if I
[ __ ] with the pure protein shakes I
wouldn't even I could sleep I could take
a nap I wouldn't have to get up it would
just be warm for a while as soon as I
got up it would I could peel it off my
ass it would just be the shape of my
hatch craft and I wouldn't even have
[ __ ] on my ass
there was a bug in my stomach oh yeah
because it came out like Rusty oatmeal
now was it a fart that went wrong I was
a fart that went it was a fart that went
wrong part that went wrong and
thank God because at least you're just
not leak and unconsciously oh wow
because that that's what old people they
just leak you know you just [ __ ] you
don't know it
yeah that's the thing you know that's
one of the reasons you know we're headed
back to diapers Why Us now when we get
older like we're headed to diapers it's
funny it's a circle it's really
everything is a circle it comes full
circle everything's Circle we're headed
like our future is is just diapers we're
gonna we will be in diapers my dad was
wearing a diaper at the end
fuzzy like a baby yeah he was getting
changed did you have to clean him I
didn't have to we had a you know we had
a couple ladies we paid off the books to
do that well a couple of Haitian ladies
come in
they definitely weren't American
I don't think anyone American does that
job anymore why we're too what happens
is you get spoiled your Society gets
spoiled you know everyone everyone wants
to be a tick tock star now
it's [ __ ] I mean it's it's yeah it's
mind-boggling it's a immigrants come
immigrants are the only ones who want to
do hard jobs hard labor good money and
go home to be with their family yeah
have dinner
right have a barbecue on the weekend
and uh and call it a day and go back to
work again yeah
that used to be the Italians the Greeks
the Irish yeah
yeah right and then and and who is the
who was just White English like white at
breakfast Tiffany yeah then they had a
weird accent back then like hello yeah
like it wasn't English but it was it was
American but not it didn't have that
thing it didn't have the clock yo it
didn't have the uh that yeah those are
there sir I did yeah I dare you well
that's not English but it was yeah
topography I'm going to Chicago tomorrow
and I love the Topography of Chicago
they talked like that I love the
Topography of Chicago yeah it was this
uh Aristocrat yeah two tickets on TWA
yeah where are those douchebags where's
TWA went out of business TWA is a hotel
at JFK
oh and here's what's sad is that I
remember using that terminal that's now
a hotel I remember going through it when
it was TWA I flew [ __ ] TWA you're a
hundred years old I'm [ __ ] wait so I
didn't even know that the terminal at
JFK in New York City one of the old TWA
which is the hotel JetBlue now right
JetBlue bought twas yeah terminal yeah
because TV was [ __ ] finished right
and the term the terminal was beautiful
too here's why it was uh art deco so it
looked like a spaceship and you had to
go to the planes you had to go through
these tubes so you went from the
spaceship was the terminal into these
tubes and you'd go out to the gates and
you jump on your your dumb plane and now
I mean of course they the two one of the
tubes is still there and it takes you to
over to JetBlue but uh you you pull in
you can stay a night in this old TWA
terminal it's this beautiful hotel with
a bar and a restaurant and that's so
cool it would be cool I mean I was
actually talking to Don about it yeah
like we should just go there one night
get a babysitter you know let Max do a
sleepover and we'll go to the TWA hotel
we'll [ __ ] stay there we'll have
dinner we'll see all these [ __ ]
flying somewhere you know maybe we'll
walk around yeah and we'll go out there
with you we want to sleep
no I'm saying I'll spend a night with
you in the TWA hotel we'll make it a
thing really yeah two Comics two cigars
in the TWA Hotel part two that'll be the
part two yeah here's here's where
airports went wrong
tell me and and this is the first nice
this is the first you had a mule kick
that went out huh yes I did yeah
and this I think this is the first uh
social justice people we dealt with
these [ __ ] anti-smokers
I don't smoke cigarettes but I am not an
anti-smoker I think people who want to
smoke a cigarette or a cigar or whatever
should have an area to [ __ ] do that
you know this we're a free country yeah
and I know it kills people I get it I
understand it's real bad for you yeah
it's terrible but you should have a
place in every airport an outdoor little
sanctuary if you want to go out and
[ __ ] smoke a butt light up a little
cigar and kill an hour you should be
able to I think they do have that I
think there's like little smoking areas
not in JFK no you can't smoke anywhere
100 no they're like [ __ ] you they just
they eliminated it
like the last place was I mean
it was Atlanta Atlanta I remember
Atlanta's smoking section
it was a room I remember those little
glass rooms you go in them and
yeah it's you just it's those rooms make
you realize how gross smoking cigarettes
is when you walk the smell of it when
you go in there yeah yeah you just did
the same thing I did so we're both
amateurs you lost one too why are you
waiting for that yeah that was even yeah
I mean wow you know what I was thinking
when you said Dawn Dawn Dawn yeah
we could use the name Dawn
to to dissect the difference between the
New York accent and the Boston accent
okay good I would say Dawn Dawn Dawn
Dawn that's it if it was coming up pure
New York it would go dawn yeah you say
it like a dawn yeah Dawn yeah it sounds
more masculine When You're Gone Gone get
me into some more dull it's almost
closer to Dawn it almost sounds like don
don the pizzas are almost ready Dawn get
the doll out yeah Dawn and you go Dawn
Dawn Dawn so there's always like a the
boss actually has like a w in there well
the Boston accent puts letters where
they're not and takes them out where
they are no idea yeah his idea idea dude
I got an idea I got an idea yeah
you understand yeah and then ka yeah we
rip that ah right the [ __ ] out of there
yeah you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
and then and we add the r where it's not
idea yeah right so you say roof roof
right so you add R's you add W's or you
take letters off you add letters or take
them off we add them yeah and we'll take
them out girl yeah I love the let me
just say something about this okay there
is nothing when you have a Boston accent
okay
it's so uh unique people know it yeah
you go anywhere though he's from Boston
and they get excited I know New Yorkers
don't because we have a rivalry but
anywhere else in the country or you know
or even in the world
they'll be like are you from Boston and
I'm like yeah how the [ __ ] do you know
right and and but the New York accent
is is kind of like a [ __ ] accent
I mean everybody's like you sound like
an [ __ ] New Yorker yeah they don't
ever say you sound like an [ __ ]
Boston person right if you're from
Boston they love it it's [ __ ] cool
it's a unique
it they're similar that's what I'm
saying we would use the word Dawn to see
the where they split because they're
similar it's nor they're both Northeast
some words are very similar like we say
car like car like hey the car's outside
yeah but this is also cool how do you
say draw draw draw draw yeah that's but
we say draw so it's more of an awe where
you go ah we go oh yeah
we go draw I say draw and coffee
coffee coffee you guys put it you put a
w yeah we sound well we're a little more
[ __ ] blue color give me a coffee
we're a little more grittier before I
scarred seven years ago
Johnny Kennedy
was there a picture hanging in your
house of John F Kennedy absolutely huh
yeah it's like an Irish thing right let
me tell you something John F Kennedy was
such a piece of [ __ ] if you thank God he
got [ __ ] shot because if he was alive
I'm gonna tell you if he was okay Jesus
if him and his brother were alive today
they'd be [ __ ] right next to [ __ ]
Bill Cosby working for the old the old
uh Protestant Garden he murdered Mallory
Monroe they're [ __ ] garbage people
they were banging I have a friend of
mine
that lived in a building in La this old
[ __ ] building Jesus you remember the
TWA [ __ ] Outlet you remember when you
were there when Marilyn Monroe died and
you got an old friend L.A how old are
you Bobby
I'm 74.
um he's got this old building you know
this uh really old building in La West
Hollywood and uh you know just you know
just old school and one of the uh
Apartments there
was used by the Kennedy boys when they
went to California they would use that
that that apartment to bang out chicks
did you think they ever Eiffel towered
Maryland
because they both were [ __ ] her
Robert and John [ __ ] Maryland do you
think this kills me to say yeah this
[ __ ] hurts me yeah to say this and I
could have just went along
but I have to know what the [ __ ] is an
Eiffel Tower I think it's when you high
five over the girl
foreign
that be the Golden Gate Bridge it could
be the Golden Gate Bridge too yeah or it
could be technically an Egyptian pyramid
you know if you yeah
why is it like this yeah over she's in
the middle she's blowing you I'm begging
her from behind and I think that's the
Eiffel Tower I mean I'm pretty sure dude
there's no way they did an Eiffel Tower
somebody
they must have listen brother they he
was banging dude a lot they were banging
they both bang Marilyn and then she dies
right
and then uh the the other brother
[ __ ] kills a chick almost [ __ ]
just walks away yeah I mean these guys
were I mean this was this is when men
were [ __ ] they could do no wrong they
just got away with [ __ ] they're an
interesting family because they're like
American royalty
and yeah they're Irish
right they were Irish Catholic which
back in the day was kind of like they
were garbage people yeah the Protestants
the wasp's father did a lot of illegal
[ __ ] oh he was he's the Original Don
coleon yeah I mean he legalized he did
what Michael wanted to do the mafia uh
they they stole that election for him
for for John FK they stay you know his
father
stole the election with the mafia helped
him get in office right yeah yeah and uh
they they're the then they became like
American royalty and then like the all
the the you know brothers and grandkids
all got into
um
politics and uh yeah a lot of they've
had a lot of tragedy JFK Jr just like
goes up in a plane
that one that one bothered me oh you
know what he was gonna run against
Hillary how is that a conspiracy too
that she took him out because remember
she wanted to run for Senate and JFK Jr
is going to run for Senate and so people
around Hillary always tend to die you
ever see you ever see that [ __ ] that
Clinton dead people list it's a long
list it's a long list yeah and she dude
let me tell you something
she is ruthless yeah I mean she's no
joke I wouldn't [ __ ] with Hillary
Clinton no you don't [ __ ] with her I
would not [ __ ] with her man she's she's
they're no joke no
no yeah I don't know it just it is
interesting to think that they were
going to run against each other in the
primary it would have been and
James Jr was very popular he took a plan
out in the fog and flew upside down he's
dead and at the I mean man was he cool
you understand Jackie O and JFK [ __ ]
yeah and made a perfect child he was a
gorgeous man perfect Kennedy he was he
had the hair
but the looks the looks were the next
level I'll tell you listen if you look
at JFK
he's good looking for back then he had a
weird eye
Duty had these round [ __ ] these like
you know yeah that was weird man like
they you know they were they were a
couple Generations out of [ __ ] you
know and what was that what was that
that wasn't like a Boston accent he's
like a Nantucket accent yeah it was uh
five score and try to drag yeah but
that's not what your country can do ask
what you can do for your country that
was that accent that back in the day
they they had these weird accents you
know but that I guess that that wasn't a
that's not a Boston accent it's like a
Rhode Island
yeah yeah Hyannis Port yeah Hyannis boy
it's like uh you know the Petrus Farm
guy you can't get there from here right
right Pepper Farm remembers yeah same
accent yeah yeah it's a weird accent
yeah yeah they were an interesting an
interesting family and and yeah so much
tragedy
I'm not a conspiracy theory guy but it
there has to be that whole family was
taken out
that doesn't happen yeah well they were
the
up until that point
there had never been anything other than
a white Anglo-Saxon Protestant president
never before JFK no and then the mob
[ __ ] made it happen mom made it
happen and then they turned on the mob
they turned into mob right yeah and then
the mob probably was part of what killed
JFK Robert Kennedy got killed by a guy
named Sirhan Sirhan I had he had it's
like hey guy you got I think your name
is redundant
it's gonna kill us again killed by a guy
named be honest Giannis yeah
Bobby Bobby kills [ __ ] uh yeah they
took them all out I read an Incredible
Book though Bobby oh my God about the
topography wow that was a book there now
yeah so I read a book uh it was called
crisis years about
about Robert Kennedy and
um cruise ships Ambassador I can't
remember his name some Russian name
during the Cuban Missile Crisis they
were meeting in hotels to kind of chill
[ __ ] out they wanted to chill [ __ ] out
really yeah they were basically going
like cruise ships got a he's gotta speak
a certain way for the pride of Russia
and all that to seem strong and all that
[ __ ] but we don't want the smoke right
and Robert was acting on you know as an
Envoy for his brother and he was going
we don't want that smoke either so let's
[ __ ] shell this out no [ __ ] we don't
want a nuclear war
so um they did do a good job of [ __ ]
avoiding the nuclear war we got close
hang on I gotta check this real quick
make sure everything's legit but still
good yeah yeah it was still [ __ ] good
all right
all right they got close to a [ __ ]
nuclear war dude we got close we got
close I mean
dude we got close and it's like
you know sometimes you got to go through
those like you got to get off TV you got
to go meet in the back room
and you know you gotta you know and it
also shows that like
there's a public Persona everyone's got
a public Persona and a private person
yeah and wrestling yeah and when [ __ ]
gets dire yeah when [ __ ] gets dire you
gotta like all right we gotta cut the
[ __ ] like we gotta we gotta talk for
real with no we gotta like [ __ ] we
can't do this
what do you think of this guy disregard
to be honest with you
is absolutely delicious
but I don't know
no here's the thing am I that's the
thing because the best cigar I ever
smoked Paul Paolo Italian I don't know
why he tells anyone to call him Paul if
my name was Paulo I would say never call
me anything but Paulo I mean it makes my
panties wet you have to deal with a
Brazilian accent uh
you know yeah Paulo he brought he was in
Cuba or whatever somehow like I somehow
he went to Cuba River and he brought us
back me and vs I think it was the
parthegos
well
uh Cubans and it was the best cigar I
ever smoked
but my thing is like am I just going oh
it's a Cuban you know what I mean is it
that thing where I'm going oh it's a
Cuban and then I kind of like convince
myself sort of like you know with the
vaccine we all think it works
but really it's just Placebo I'm just
kidding now this [ __ ] video is gonna
have a [ __ ] CDC warning on I'm just
joking I'm vax boosted
I I but here's my theory you know what
I'm saying here's my here's my the way I
look at that who cares if if somehow
that made the cigar better for you
because you thought it was a Cuban yeah
Cuban somehow is a placebo for you yeah
who gives you but I can't live in that
but that I know I
but that means like we're stupid because
you're stupid I mean I know this is a
good cigar yeah this is a delicious
cigar I'll tell you what I've smoked
Cubans that I've been like garbage I've
been like yeah this is all right I don't
like it this is my type of cigar this is
a meat mild
you know it's got some spice it's not
too spicy right right you from the
second you smoke it to right now
right it's still the same cigar to me I
love that I think that was perfectly
perfectly described it's light has a
hint of spice to it it's delicious yeah
a little bit on the side of your tongue
when it's too much on the side of your
tongue yeah and you gotta clean your
palate because you have [ __ ] you know
that I need to eat I need to have a
steak with that yeah but like this right
now rolling in here just water and
lighting this up when we lit it up to
right now it's the same cigar it's a
nice mild
hanging out you don't have to worry
about what sorry wow yeah I'm sure
there's an ashtray I know yeah well you
missed it too once once I'm one ahead of
you yeah you beat me I'm two it's one to
two
but I think uh I know I I think this is
to me
the length of it
and the the the the
mildness of it
is really just I'm enjoying this I am
tobacco's my advice I Can't Get Enough
tobacco I I have to I put snooze in my
mouth all day it's a Swedish news you
know what is that it's uh you just put
it in your mouth
yeah look at that you just put it in
your uh put in your mouth and put it up
there and I do it all day and you know
tobacco is just I love it so yeah I do I
can tell when a cigar is good I'm a
cigar smoker I love cigars I've been
trying to imagine a question about this
when you're bringing it in you when
you're getting it in your mouth right
yep
[Laughter]
it's a weird way to phrase that when you
get it in your mouth I don't like that
that's the way you took it but it made
you smile yeah and light up yeah it did
yeah
like I was gonna give you a present yeah
what you're gonna give me what you're a
guy that lights people up though you you
light people out
or you're you're you're you're you're
like you light people up you have a
cheery fun affable yeah you got like you
have there's a twinkle in your eyes yeah
but you know I you're a twinkly
[ __ ] you're a twinkling you just
twinkly yeah you're like happy like it
makes people you make people happy
you're certain people
no no and even as a comedian you you
you're one of those guys who go
everyone's up yeah yeah you like it's
like you know you make everyone feel
good oh thank you yeah I like that
you're a guy that uh is you're happy to
see that I'm happy it's Bobby
your voice is funny everything's funny
yeah that's good man I I take that as a
beautiful compliment yeah you're like an
uplift it's like a you know you you
twinkle you awake in everything you're
an awakener yeah make everyone happy
yeah it's like yeah Bobby's here [ __ ]
Bobby Kelly nobody goes like Jesus
[ __ ] box yeah no nobody nobody does
oh [ __ ] G Bobby no only you know well
well you know what it's weird is now in
my life I'm so happy right now
I can't
I I get nervous
you don't want to [ __ ] it up I just I
know that life doesn't work like that I
know life doesn't let you be happy every
day all day forever I know things happen
that you know kind of [ __ ] you up you
know what I mean and you have to deal
with but like today I came home I flew
home
and uh I'm talking to somebody on the
phone I was talking to Ari and we think
it's arrogant just not to cut you off
but I think exactly we say we flew home
no some arrogant guy started that Trend
we didn't do [ __ ] we should say I was
flown home
you ever noticed that I mean because
even with a car you'd go I took a cab
it's only the with the plane we go like
I flew home it's like were you the pilot
no you were sitting in coach
I assume
no first class yeah
you should have bumped up
Platinum there was many many miles in
Comfort plus
yeah
thank God because there's a couple fans
on the plane too yeah we're in first oh
and someone recognized coaches yeah and
they're in first yeah and you're gonna
walk by them
a few times yes I don't know if there's
anything worse than that there's nothing
I'll tell you what's worse than that
when there's a comic beneath you yeah
that's In First Class oh and you're
gonna walk by him or her and Coach I
never had that happen but I have had and
I don't know if I've had someone in
first recognize me but I've had someone
in coach where you're just like hey
how's it going and then like you like
yeah I'm a coach yeah I always go
Comfort plus I'll never go coach you've
had I'll never go back to coach oh I was
doing coach till like yesterday dude I
do Comfort plus I was doing coach till I
think Virgie told me there was a problem
with that oh there's a problem yeah
because I'm like a low maintenance guy
I'll [ __ ] climb my coach I hear you
dude but just spend the extra 50. I know
on Comfort plus you're bored before
those Savages yeah and you're above them
you're right be you're right behind it
wait have so have you ever stayed a
coach with you a fan recognizer they
were in first class oh [ __ ] dude I
walked by a guy
and he looked at me like where are you
going yeah yeah Bobby where are you what
did you pretend like you were going to
the bathroom and you'd be right back oh
no no I was in Comfort plus like right
there so like I was behind him it was
the curtain so you were having a combo
and he was telling you how much he he
was telling you how much he loved you
and how funny and then a curtain came in
between
students was like I'm sorry wow oh yeah
oh that's funny that's a funny visual
yeah it's a it's a tough one dude it's a
[ __ ] tough one did you were you
tempted to explain like yeah yeah sold
out flight I had to get this one no I
had to catch this one no I I get so uh
I was so when that happened I was just
like if you got to take the hit yeah you
gotta at least I'm not coach right you
you've come from Comfort plus I think
the way to get out of that one is you go
like yeah book flight you know I had to
get home I was I was supposed to be on a
later one but I got to get home because
Dawn
yeah so I always thought someone said I
got to do something have you ever been
on a flight when there's like uh
like a military person or you know
somebody that need would really enjoy
that first class would you ever give
that up to somebody else
if I paid for it yes
okay you gotta get specific all right
there's a [ __ ] Marine
and he's on the plane he's in coach
middle seat
and you're in first class give up my dad
though yeah it's only a two and a half
hour flight
but I went to college I'm an officer I'd
be an officer
um just the Marine
is you have both his all his limbs he's
missing one foot and he's got a Purple
Heart he's got a Purple Heart he's got
the Purple Heart
now what do you get the Purple Heart for
eign
I wouldn't give that if Jesus Christ was
on the back of the plane with no shoes
on I'd be like listen JC if my elderly
mother fell I'd still tell her to put
her back in coach I'd tell my wife to go
[ __ ] herself with Max like this I'll see
in a Roomba [ __ ] yeah I have no way of
giving up the bed one you ever get mint
no the best I've done is the bed to Los
Angeles the bed to Los Angeles for mint
to L.A or oh what's mint mint is uh
JetBlue's first class
and what I like about it they got two
and then one two and then one so you
know most first class have two two two
two two two Jet Blue said [ __ ] it two
and then one if you get the one you're
in the you're in that aisle that that
section by yourself well that's like the
bed you're by yourself oh it's a bed too
it's a bed they're all beds yeah mint is
bad yeah bad yeah they do pack us in
there like goddamn sardines they gotta
do it yeah it's expensive to [ __ ] fly
yeah you got to pay that think about
what it is think about what we're doing
we're getting up there's a two guys or
three guys
that are I mean pretty much Geniuses we
don't know how many you just proved you
don't know how many guys are up there it
depends on the size of the flame oh it's
two or three there's two if it's a
smaller plan if it's a big plan you
gotta have the extra guy three guys you
gotta have three guys now what's the
third guy do if something is the cold
pilot yeah if someone oh he's the yeah
yeah he's the other guy
some if they have to take a nap or
something you know the bigger planes
they have like uh little to take a nap
they're at work Buddy you take a nap at
work those long flights yeah those those
stewardess you ever see them disappear
for a couple hours they go take a nap
huh there's a bigger beds downstairs
downstairs buddy there's a downstairs
on what planes are there downstairs are
the bigger ones maybe the double deckers
no not just have you ever been on one of
those double deckers with your bar
upstairs and all that [ __ ] yeah I never
got upstairs though
wait on the big planes there's a
downstairs they have a downstairs the
big newer planes because these they have
to take a nap they can't
be [ __ ] sleep sleepy underneath
flight you know what I mean so I didn't
know that they have little uh like they
go down they go down this little [ __ ]
elevator could you take one of them down
there and [ __ ] them [ __ ] yeah yeah you
go downstairs little elevator and
there's little beds they can lie down
wait you blow in my head right now
there's a [ __ ] elevator on a plane
glad you I'm glad you put head at the
end of that wait wait a second what size
of plane is this a 747 has an elevator
I'm not [ __ ] calm dudes I'm not John
Travolta I don't know the in the the
details I don't know it's a you know I
don't know what it is but I I talked to
a stewardess one time I was like where
did you go I think she was [ __ ] with
you man it was nice I looked it up on
YouTube dude I've been in a plane all
there is is a bathroom and a cart area
not true the bigger planes I talked to
her I go where did you go she goes I
went downstairs I I uh I napped for a an
hour
um an hour and a half we all have to
take certain naps at certain times go
get a rest we get a break
and uh I went downstairs I was like
downstairs she's like yeah we have a
little uh
we have a little uh you take the
elevator down and there's a two beds you
get little cots like you know like bunk
beds and then go in there and take a nap
and she said that there's an elevator
where's the where was the elevator where
would you find the elevator it's like in
the middle on the big planes well you
know the big plane when you go left to
go first class and then this business
and then this [ __ ] yeah the big big
ones yeah so going if you're going to
like transatlantic oh yeah yeah the the
big ones oh you're going over the ocean
yeah yeah they take a [ __ ] nap dude
they have beds wow yeah I didn't know
that you ever see them just disappear
where do they go
no no I've never seen him disappear
I mean disappear like go bye-bye yeah I
thought they you know I've seen them sit
in their seats I've seen them back there
like on their phones I've seen them
giggling yeah yeah
have you ever you
ever find yourself very attracted to a
stewardess
today do you
yeah but when I flew to Chicago on
Friday yeah oh yeah she had uh is it
possible to pick up a stewardess if
you're not Tiger Woods I I yeah it is
but you can't pick him up on the plane
right you got to pick them up at the
hotel they go to
if you ever read if you're ever if
you're ever at a hotel and you see that
that car load of stewardesses get out
yeah just go to the bar right because
that's where they're going they're going
to the bar they're gonna get a meal
there and they're gonna probably get a
couple drinks later they'll probably put
the little skivvies on go down and get a
drink if you know go to the Box start
shooting the [ __ ] it's a great job if
you want to like if you want to sleep
around it's a great job
because you're in you're in San Diego
one night you're banging and you're out
I can't get attached before the internet
and all that stuff Pilots use a lot of
Pilots used to have like two families
that happened a lot really yeah like
where a pilot would have like a
completely separate family because they
used to do these long legs and then
they'd stay in those towns yeah before
you can't do that [ __ ] now you can't do
it now but they they it used to happen
when Pilots would have two full families
yeah and the family one family would not
know about the other family it's crazy
but that was that that happened a lot
back in the day a kid right oh dudes
would do that yeah I mean come on
is different Guma is different all right
I'm gonna gas this out
what does that mean oh you're gonna push
and do that whole thing where you push
well you light the cigar
you know the thing is and it is true
are you blowing forward
um
a great Tony V
top Billy bird that Billy Burke taught
me that uh and you gas it out so you
light it when you're down here and it
burns all the [ __ ] because you're
dragging all that [ __ ] through the cigar
so when you gas that out you're crapping
out all the
you
blow forward a little bit and then now
it's let me see
like the beginning of the scar yeah you
know it's it is true when the cigar gets
a little lower why does it taste better
why does it like get better as it goes
on when you get lower it's just it it is
it's like a wine it's like the flavors
change everything changes I guess
because there's less it's more it's more
dense it's a little more condensed yeah
it's a little harder you know what I
mean this one's a good one it's got it's
gotten better mine's gotten better as
it's gotten lower has yours to you right
now after I gassed it it's [ __ ] it's
still amazing I'm enjoying this so much
it's really good and I love it that
we're doing it in my my smoking shed how
would you explain to a person who's not
a cigar smoker what makes a good cigar
because the way I would explain a good
wine to someone because like you know
you got these connoisseurs and then like
lay people don't know what's good
what the way I explain I think I got a
good one for wine right it's I like a
wine I think a good wine
should go down
like
a person trying to sneak out of their
house on steps Goes Down Smooth no noise
smooth yeah like you're wearing socks
you don't hear any you know it's you
want you don't want to get burned okay
it just goes down smooth like butter
like that's a good one that's a good way
to explain how a good wine should be
well I think your palette the more
cigars you smoke the more you want you
know what I mean like all the guys at my
cigar bar they're smoking heavy cigars
they don't [ __ ] with light things they
don't really like like mild cigars they
wanna they want a bat they want because
they need it because their ticket their
nicotine level
is higher they need something more in
their tolerance they're tolerant so when
they smoke a cigar
they're not going to taste it if it's
too mild you know they're not going to
smoke a Monte Cristo but what makes a
good smoke like why is a Philly Philly
[ __ ] tobacco yeah it's [ __ ] it's tobacco
and you can taste the [ __ ] cigarettes
you know it's cigarettes are yeah it's
not even tobacco it dried out it's not
even it's like paper and tobacco it's
the [ __ ] it's the worst tobacco
you could get is a is a [ __ ]
cigarette it's garbage tobacco yeah and
people I mean it's just crazy and then
this premium cigars
is the best tobacco you can get
this is it right yeah and you gotta it
has to be well maintained it's got to be
humid all the time you get so much that
goes into it yeah it can't if it gets
too dry from the second it grows do they
cut it
you know so they they they hang it in
the barn
till they ship it off to be fermented to
some
some lady grabs it and starts cutting it
up to roll to putting it in a box
to letting it sit
into to where it got to us yeah yeah we
learned this from the natives
what do you mean Native Americans
tobacco they were smoking it
and we fell in love with it Europeans
that's it you know I
I would I would like to find out where
the first cigar was made
it's a good question it's probably uh
probably the Caribbean right I don't
know but tobacco the Indians would put
it in the pipe right and they'd smoke
the tobacco pipe and then uh the
Europeans got a hold of that they sent
it to Europe people fell in love with it
there was a demand for it
then you know we started getting tobacco
plantations and you know didn't pay
people yeah people didn't get paid
of course that was bad
they worked in there and they worked at
those you know uh plantations right and
then it became that was bad that that
part was bad Oh I thought you were
talking about no
slavery for a second that's what I'm
talking about I didn't know you were
talking about that I thought you were
talking about like you know workers in
England getting you know pay with beans
no I'm talking about that was bad yeah
that was working and not getting paid as
bad slavery has always been bad it's bad
it's never been done no there's no way
to
say it's good
it's such a weird thing
to just catch making people work and not
paying them to capture human beings
but then there's the part of it where
you go like
back in the day if you wanted to get
something done right like if you wanted
to like you know they use slaves to
build the pyramids or they you you know
everything even in Dubai a lot of people
don't know but Dubai like it was built
by like essentially like kind of
indentured service which is like you
know it's like a it's like a PR way of
saying slave that was white slaves yeah
call it what you want you know it's like
there's ways around it so a lot of those
buildings were built by like
indentured like Indian like poor Indian
like the Arabs kind of kind of enslaved
these people they don't call it that but
it kind of was but how else do you get
people to do horrific work that needs to
be done if you want to build something
nobody wants to do if you don't
you gotta enslave someone that's maybe
why that's why slavery's been around
forever everyone's been enslaved people
have been enslaving people since the
beginning where is slavery still going
on
uh in the Middle East they still got
some slavery they have slavery yeah
[ __ ] Saudi Arabia didn't Outlaw it I
think until like
1974. Jesus yes or like 64 or something
like that kinda yeah
I mean England was the first I think to
Outlaw yeah with the first one yeah they
were the first ones
yeah but they were also you know
they were also doing a lot of it yeah
yeah
cool yeah yeah but it was the way of the
world it was weird that there's still
slavery and that's not the world's topic
like that's not what we're all going hey
you guys yeah knock it the [ __ ] off cut
it out like why like think of all the
social justice people in the world that
want change they want you know
everything here to be changed right fine
but why don't those people and all the
other people in every other country that
are you know yelling at their government
or whatever why don't we find where
slavery is still going on and all of us
like Farm Aid you know what I mean go
hey guys knock it off well I think we
kind of did well you can't stop you know
you can't stop them why you'd have to go
over there and invade the country and
rescue people when has that stopped us
that's a good point well I mean I mean
when the [ __ ] is that hey look if you're
enslaved and there's no oil in your land
I'm sorry you're you're left to your own
devices
we know we don't want to go over there
get a bunch of sandstone yeah
oh you gotta and pretty soon that's not
gonna matter pretty soon it's gonna be
that my whatever they use for the
battery
ah what is that they might submitting
something yeah whatever the place is
gonna have that pretty soon they'll be
you'll you'll hear whatever this is how
you can tell that it's all about the
resource natural resources and whatever
story they make up is just to motivate
people to go fight there right because
that's how you'll tell pretty soon we'll
be going in there'll be some Skirmish
there'll be like some terrorists over in
some country where they have all the
mining battery minerals that we need and
we'll be like yeah they're attacking us
and then next you know be over there
it'll be a different wherever that [ __ ]
is I'm assume it's in Africa because
somehow Africa's got all the [ __ ]
minerals yeah yeah it's the motherland
they got a lot of [ __ ] down there they
got a lot of [ __ ] yeah so
wherever wherever that is we'll be
there'll be a war there soon and it'll
be a total excuse the story will be
something else but we'll be in there you
know they'll be like oh they got Weapons
of Mass uh instruction or whatever
they're like yeah you know they it's
it's fun they're threat to us it's funny
it's Avatar
I mean look at the University oh yeah
yeah it's like Avatar yeah I mean oh but
you know that's what it is you got to
have like all Empires are looking for
resources right because we're like we're
on top of the hill so we want to consume
the good [ __ ] and we don't want to pay a
lot for it right so and the places that
have all these minerals are usually not
as militarily militarily sophisticated
so we go in there and we kind of take it
everyone's been doing the Romans did it
with like grain or whatever the tobacco
and sugar whatever was the big thing of
the time spices spices you just go in
remember what spices were a big thing
bananas have been big banana was big
bananas we conquered we [ __ ] you know
we we did a coup for bananas yeah and
coffee coffee yeah paprika yeah remember
the the what is it the spice uh
dude if your country has some [ __ ] keep
it a secret
like wakanda yeah don't let it out like
we'll build a force field where they
think it's just a jungle but it's really
a city yeah don't [ __ ] ever share
your bananas don't let them know if
someone comes in a boat and it's like
I'm lost don't be like ah come for
dinner and then we'll go oh well can I
have one of those bananas yeah we've got
we grow bananas here because it's the
best banana I've ever had they're gonna
you're gonna get [ __ ] birds that an
iPhone does a tick tock you're [ __ ]
yeah he's a he's a food blogger yeah if
yeah you'll be [ __ ] yeah it's like uh
uh uh El Presidente from uh Barstool
[ __ ] blows up a pizza place Yeah that
poor guy was gonna retire now he can't
because he's [ __ ] he's got six deep out
the door yes he runs out of dough at
noon yeah it's like dude I gotta make
this money yeah yeah do you know uh
Norway for example oh hang on yeah no I
don't gotta take a show I'm making sure
everything runs yeah because I'm not
really oh [ __ ] see this one stopped what
he's saying about
for example Norway Norway
did you know that they
are one of the biggest oil suppliers in
the world Norway Norway those those
[ __ ] blonde people that when they
walk down the street they don't even
move yeah they make you move yeah yeah
so they have a ton of oil
but they're smart they don't talk about
it they don't talk about they keep it
quiet right they keep recording that's
why they don't get [ __ ] robbed you
don't [ __ ] everyone you don't wear your
chain at the club you don't wear your
Rolex
no keep it quiet keep it quiet they
don't [ __ ] have outside air
conditioning they're not driving around
in turbines and Mercedes and
Lamborghinis like the Middle East
okay because oil is basically the drug
and that's our that's their drug dealers
right and drug dealers get robbed by who
Omar from The Wire right that's us we're
Omar we're all so we start coming to
Noah they're like Omar's coming as soon
as they [ __ ] up and buy like a gold
watch or something oh Mom we're showing
up going Norway yeah we heard you
[ __ ] need some Freedom where
are you got good salmon are you not free
you got some [ __ ] oil yeah run all
the salmon blonde [ __ ] while you're
at it right yeah they keep it quiet
that's what you got to do
as we are are we are we really we're
just [ __ ]
we just [ __ ] we're just we're the
[ __ ] we're the [ __ ]
but it's it's it's gonna be gone soon
I think we're in it I mean China's got
to be the thing the thing that could
save us is a good War a good War we're
good at that yeah but this is what
scares me about a war
I got a I got a nine-year-old by the
time we go to war he's going to be
[ __ ] eligible for the draft I don't
think men should go to war anymore I
believe in
equality
you think it's true women I think women
should go this time we have all the
artillery you think it should be trans
women and no just women just women just
women
I think just women should go why because
we [ __ ] went for all before there was
like weapons and you wanted equality you
wanted equality and now we're gonna stay
home technology made it so you could
work and you could you know because
let's be honest like before there was
technology be honest let's be honest
before there was technology and all that
type of [ __ ] yeah somebody had to put
the there was no Jamaican nannies back
in right so you had to kind of stay home
and [ __ ] and feed the kids exactly
but now we made it so there's bottles
and you know there's other things guys
can you know take estrogen shots and
grow and nurture kit I got a 24-hour
Walgreens I'll get I'll get some uh some
uh formula right now exactly and now we
have artillery we got guns we got you
could shoot a gun we got drones we got
drones right we'll stay home with the
babies right and you go fight I'm in
that would be dough be awesome yeah
it'll be intimidating too first because
first of all you disarm them right a
bunch of women's Marines show up the
guy's like hey ladies and then they
[ __ ] Charlie's Angels that's what you
guys want right yeah you want to be
Charlie's Angels you want to be Kill
Bill you don't [ __ ] do a karate
here's the problem do it for real here's
the problem with that yeah okay they're
gonna come back and then we start
[ __ ] each other while they're not
like the Green State
it just becomes one big dude egg
we just suck at each other off the
cigars yeah I don't know if I got a
cigar in my mouth that you're clogging
and here's your thing the women around
fighting we're safe yeah but even we
don't have to go gay because we're
missing the women like they do in jail
or they did an ancient Greece we don't
have to do that because guess what we
can do now well we can make chicks how
inject them with [ __ ] estrogen and
make them so you can make me into a hot
chick I [ __ ] can I can yeah I mean
they make trans women I can make you
into a chick I'll just be I just grow
I'm gonna run out of Tricks we could
make other ones and guess what those
ones you can [ __ ] and they don't get
pregnant uh so it's fun this is perfect
it's a perfect idea it's perfect it's
perfect I love it how great dude like if
they if we kill all the chick because
always thing was the thing was you can't
you can't send the women first of all
because they're weaker what are you
gonna do
um and you had to carry axes and [ __ ]
and they just didn't have the strength
for it you ever see like those videos
where two women coppers struggling with
the suspect that a male civilian has to
just come and help them I just saw it I
saw it today yeah two women just
struggling and then a guy just comes and
you're like this one girl yelling I mean
really being [ __ ] to this dumb guy and
this guy was like go [ __ ] yourself and
she tried to grab he could get the [ __ ]
off me and she grabbed him again he goes
yeah then he was rolling around and he
was like [ __ ] you and then some dude
came out of nowhere tackled him put him
down held his hand behind his back and
he was like all right all right and then
she took over I saw the same clip yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah so it's like but now
you got guns and [ __ ] go fight yeah and
then uh if we lose the women because
they're dying in war like we used to die
in war we just make new women nice just
make them turn men into women well the
women that come back for more my my
problem with this though is that what if
your wife does come back she makes it
back she's all [ __ ] in the head right
yeah and then she goes into menopause
you gotta [ __ ] you got a crazy War
chick seeing flashbacks every time she
has fireworks she loses her mind right
she's probably alcoholic and then she's
pre-menopausal that's a nightmare that's
a nightmare that's a [ __ ] nightmare
that's why he probably uh he got right
into the laws that you can put them down
like a coyote he's gotta put him down
yeah he's gotta put him down yeah baby
you guys can't handle we got I don't
think women can handle it so we just
make we'll make women but they get put
down let's grow them we don't do it they
put them down before they come on yeah
honey I'm sorry you're not gonna make it
home you want to FaceTime yeah say
goodbye because you ain't going home
you're not gonna be put down but Giannis
has a Giannis made Bobby Robert Kelly
into a [ __ ] a hot Puerto Rican girl
yeah I made a replacement all the women
were at War but we made we made uh and
then we'd just be living in a society
yeah with a bunch of dudes and women who
used to who transitioned right and it's
a great you just marry your boy and one
of your picks which one and sometimes
you can switch switch it up yeah you
just you just turn your flip your boy
flip it like I need a girl I bet that
all the women are fighting so we'll I'll
be the girl I like it we all live like
Nero that's how you end civilization
then you go out with a bang then you
drop a nuke everyone holds hands sings
We are the world and we disappear
all right listen we gotta rate these
cigars
this is at the end right now
what do you think about this cigar this
cigar
okay
with scale
none one five or a box
a box
this is a box this is uh as good as
cigar as I've ever smoked I mean this is
yep I gotta agree with you if you can
get yourself
uh this punch
it's a double Corona
Cuban these are and these are these are
attainable you can get these what you
got to do is Strike up a friendship with
Russell Peters
no you know you can get these you can go
you can go and kick them in America
right are we is there still there yeah
yeah you know I'm so mad [ __ ] Obama
is gonna end that I thought he did end
it for a second Trump [ __ ] put it
back in oh is that what happened yeah
because they're Communists right but the
Obama was I mean look you got to make
exceptions for cigars dude if they they
were about to put Starbucks Kentucky
Fried Chicken in Cuba we were they're
gonna put a [ __ ] holiday in express
we're about to go down to Cuba dude yeah
like a vacation day we're about to go
vacation right past [ __ ] Puerto Rico
right [ __ ] past everything and we
would have been we would it would have
been amazing
but no it's over but if you have a
chance you can get these punch double
Corona it is I mean this is one of my I
could smoke this every day it's a really
it's a this is a luxury everyday cigar
nice and Light
it's well when you get a box of Cubans
though
you gotta [ __ ] you gotta my thing
with cigars
look you want a horde the thing with
cigars you wind up hoarding you wind up
going [ __ ] I'm keeping these because you
want to keep them for good okay you want
to keep them you can't do that you can't
[ __ ] do it because then what if you
die and you don't get a chance to smoke
you can't you can't do it cigars were
meant to be given and smoked I'm gonna
give you these two
those are feet Bobby listen you're gonna
make me cry I want you to take these and
I want you to smoke them you get one
foot if you just said why don't you take
these and stick them up your ass take
those those are for you I'm gonna sell
them on the black market you can't no
I'm gonna smoke these but the thing is
here's the thing I I don't have a
humidor
I give those back to me I'll come back
and smoke them with you how's that how
about you take one medicine take one all
right I'll take one I'll smoke it
tomorrow yeah put in a Ziploc you know
you could just get a sponge and do that
how long how long can you not have this
in a humidor when and have it still I
mean put in a Ziploc bag tonight I'll
give you a big Ziploc okay go get a all
you do go to go to the gas station get a
babita pack most people know you buy a
babita pack for a couple bucks put it in
a Ziploc that's a humidor
how much does a punch Havana box go for
I mean this is an expensive box it's an
expensive box yeah Russell Peters is one
of the most generous people I've ever
met
take to
you want to take two put them in a
Ziploc get a babita go to your gas
station tomorrow that sells cigars go to
the smoke shop I'm taking one all right
I'm gonna come back and smoke that one
with you is that okay I mean yeah of
course we'll come back and do like just
a regular night well we're not on camera
we're smoking
that's it so I'm saying a box you're
saying a box I'm saying it's one of the
best cigars I've ever smoked I put this
up with the pot the gas that I smoked
the Cuban pot Degas this is maybe the
best cigar I've ever smoked it's awesome
this is incredible and it's gotten
better as it's gotten lower now it's
peaking right now and I'm about to guess
if I stick it into my ass and farting on
it
good old trick I learned from zilly B
from Brooklyn back in the day
I wanna know about silly B all right
we're gonna enjoy the rest of these
cigars now this is remember two Comics
two cigars that's all you need you out
there if you're a comic you got a friend
that enjoys cigars you get the same
cigar you smoke it talk about it at the
beginning middle and end and then you
rate it none one five or a box and we'll
put it up on the YouTube page it doesn't
have to be Ari and me it doesn't have to
be Ari and somebody else so me with
somebody else it can be any combo you
could do it with version you could film
it send it to us we'll throw it up there
this is a community podcast I love that
people who love smoking cigars talking
[ __ ] philosophizing and making each
other laugh that's what the whole show
is about I had a blast thanks for being
on it brother
Shake all right yeah we solved
everything I can't wait to transition